des enveloppes jaunes accrochés aux
arbres une publicité comme une autre
pour certains mouvements religieux
prosélyte
plus surprenant en revanche pour
l'étudiant tourangeaux qui les a
découvertes leurs auteurs le centre
d'accueil universel un groupe originaire
du brésil récemment installé à tour est
soupçonné de dérives sectaires lucas
chopin avec paul boyer moi et un ami on
se promener ici sur ce sentier parce
qu'on n'avait jamais jamais emprunté et
donc entendant ici on aperçut une
enveloppe jaune
on peut d'ailleurs encore voir la
ficelle hugo et étudiants et c'est par
hasard qu'il a découvert il ya quelques
jours
d'étranges messages accrochés aux arbres
du campus universitaire grandmont à
l'intérieur de cette enveloppe qui avait
une sorte de tracts un petit papier avec
marquez et briser le silence
elle peut aussi est une phrase centrale
et c'est cette phrase là en fait qu'ils
m'ont donné des des suspicions comme
quoi c'était pas ce n'était pas vraiment
une vraie prévention j'ai vu que c'était
un
un groupe évangélique surveillé par les
organismes de lutte contre les dérives
sectaires en cause en effet un certain
centre d'accueil universel une église
évangélique internationale qui a une
adresse à tour nous nous sommes rendus à
l'église tourangelle du centre d'accueil
universel pour tenter d'en savoir plus
sur place impossible d'obtenir une
interview
mais le pasteur un jeune brésilien
rejette toutes les accusations qui
pèsent contre lui
s'ils admettent une maladresse avec
l'opération des enveloppes il assure
avoir agi pour aider son prochain
mais qu'on ne s'y trompe pas le centre
d'accueil universelle est bien connue de
l'association de défense des familles et
de l'individu qui aide les proches de
personnes victimes dans prise secteur
c'est le nouveau nom de l'église
universelle du royaume de dieu quand une
ambiance brésilienne extrêmement riche
exprimant prospère extrêmement puissant
les ressorts si on peut dire c'est bon
c'est le pouvoir
on les ressort le plus pour haïm oron le
siège national situé à paris est le seul
habilité à s'exprimer publiquement
contacté il n'a pour le moment pas donné
suite à nos sollicitations